welcome to the show you know we spend a
lot of time in this culture a lot of
time and energy
supposedly exposing attacking weeding
out forms of bigotry and this this
zealousness to get rid of bigotry could
be a good thing
even in overzealousness even an
overzealousness that leads to sometimes
to calling something bigotry even when
it isn't bigotry that could be a a price
worth paying except that the problem is
our crusade against bigotry is of course
rather selective and inconsistent and
self contradictory and hypocritical and
what we discover in the end is that
we're no different than any culture in
the past all cultures have had their
accepted bigotries and their unaccepted
bigotries there are acceptable bigotry
and unacceptable and and that's the same
for us now to root out and reject all
bigotry that would be novel that would
be that would be unique that would be
progress and as I said maybe even a
price maybe even worse worth the price
of overzealousness but that's not our
situation we have simply chosen
different bigotries as acceptable and
different ones is unacceptable so it was
a lateral move not a progression and
when I say we of course I mean the
powerful forces in our culture not you
and me necessarily but media academia
Hollywood government and so on which
brings us to a perfect example of
acceptable bigotry in our culture today
this example provided to you by CNN an
alleged news network I'll just play the
clip for you if you haven't seen it yet
here is Don Lemon with two other guys
laughing at and mocking millions of
working-class Americans watch this he
also knows deep in his heart that Donald
Trump couldn't find Ukraine in a map if
you had the letter U and a picture of an
actual physical crane that's next to it
he knows that this is you know an
administration defined by ignorance of
the world and so that's partly him
playing to their base and playing to
their audience you know the the the
credulous Boomer rube demo
that backs Donald Trump that wants to
think that that that dog Trump's a smart
one in there Oh y'all know y'all elitist
you would lead us with your geography
and your maps and your spelling given
the my path you're reading yeah you're
reading you know your geography no in
other countries sipping your latte all
those lines on the map only they may
lead us nowhere Ukraine is sorry I
apologize it was Rick's fault
I blame Rick good sorry that was it good
what I needed that okay so listen okay
okay first of all my first problem is
that it's not funny the worst the worst
sin that any joke can commit is failing
to be funny and if it's if a joke
succeeds in being funny then it's
redeemed itself no matter the content of
the joke really
but it's not funny and the reason why
it's not funny is it being funny isn't
the point
when when Don Lemon is cackling like a
slap-happy drunk and says oh I needed
that what he needed was an excuse to
mock people he hates that was the
delight the delight in that quote humor
for him and for the other people on
camera is just it was an outlet a way of
venting hatred for this group of people
that's all
it wasn't the humor that anyone needed
because there wasn't any humor there
there was no wit or anything like that
this was just sheer mockery mockery out
of spite and hate and that kind of
mockery is never funny not because it's
offensive
because Martin and I'm not saying that
mockery itself is never funny
mockery can be extremely funny but when
you're mocking people simply because you
hate their guts and for no other reason
it's not gonna be funny because there
needs to be some respect or at least
some kind of understanding in humor for
it to be funny for it to be actually
humor and not you not just you not just
you ranting and raving now the second
thing quickly and you're just speaking
for myself I don't care at all just to
clarify here for anyone who doesn't
understand what people are upset about
and I I think I speak for a lot of other
people but for myself anyway I don't
care at all about the first part of this
where they're making fun of Donald Trump
that doesn't bother me bother me I will
never be offended by insults directed at
politicians
I think insulting politicians is as
American as apple pie I think it's a I
think it's patriotic I think it's our
patriotic duty to to insult and mock
politicians I'm fine with that
I'd rather err on the side of
disrespecting politicians than err on
the side of giving them too much
reverence or any reverence because we
shouldn't have any reverence at all for
politicians in this country and I do
think that there are too many people on
both sides of the aisle who err too much
on the side of reverence I don't think
it's up it's not a left first right
thing I think it's a matter of the human
condition there are some people who are
inclined to fall in the cults of
personality and so on so there are some
Trump supporters like that just like
there were some Obama supporters like
that and other politicians as well have
supporters like this who who can't stand
any mockery of their guy and have again
reverence for him I think that's a
problem and this is one of the things
that separates us from places like Iran
and Saudi Arabia in this country you can
get on the TV and you can run ruthlessly
mock our politicians and powerful people
and they can't do anything to you I
think it's good for them it's good for
them to experience that to be reminded
they're just people they're human beings
they're just bureaucrats they're not
kings
good for us to remember that about them
so that I'm fine with now to do it on an
on a supposedly unbiased news network is
embarrassing and and and inappropriate
obviously but whatever I don't care
insult insult politicians all you want
it's not gonna offend me problem is it
doesn't stop there
of course the Trump stuff is only the
first five seconds it goes on for
another minute directed at clearly
directed specifically at white
blue-collar especially southern people
and the joke the quote-unquote joke is
that they are dumb Hicks who can't read
and can't spell and can't figure out how
to use a map that's the joke so this is
bigotry plain and simple
mocking a politician that's not bigotry
mocking millions of Democrat of
Americans based on their racial and
socio-economic demographic that's
bigotry and we'll talk more about this
in just a second but first a word from
our friends at VIN Charo watches you
know with this new year it's time to get
started on improving yourself no one
knows that better than one of my
favorite sponsors and that's been chair
oh these guys just they know how
important it is to look and feel your
best and they're here to keep you
motivated through 2020 and beyond if
you're looking to upgrade your look
don't waste money on a cheap cookie
cutter watch that doesn't get you
noticed
finding a watch that's stylish bold and
built to last the thing is it can cost a
pretty penny can be pretty expensive and
so a lot of times if you want to get a
watch and you don't want to spend
exorbitant amounts of money that's when
you end up with the cheap ugly cookie
cutter watch well you don't need to do
that pinch arrow is changing the
paradigm here they believe that you
deserve to look good no matter your
budget you deserve better than settling
for something underwhelming so head over
to VIN Charo watches calm slash walls
you can check out my favorite pics take
advantage of my special discount while
you shop there as well remember to use
Walsh the code walls while you're
shopping then Cheryl understands the
frustrations of online shopping and
these guys get it that's why they're
making it as easy as possible for you
you get free shipping 30-day returns and
they've also got reviews on the site you
can go and look for yourself the 20,000
five-star reviews should tell you you
know don't take it from me don't even
take it from Vincenzo himself take it
from the people that have bought the
product and they're gonna tell you how
they feel about it and it's just rave
reviews all over the place so you want
to pass up on this deal go to VIN Charo
watches calm that's VI and C ero watches
calm forward-slash Walsh and use my
discount code walls for a discount at
checkout don't pay full price on these
beautiful timepieces you don't need need
to pay full price just remember to use
my code Walsh when you're there than
Cheryl watches dot-com all right so back
to the cackling hyenas on CNN I want you
to imagine this imagine that imagine
that exact same segment that we just
played for you except on Fox
during the Obama years
directed at Obama's urban voters
imagine that
if anyone who is skeptical that this is
bigotry we're dealing with
well imagine in that scenario
exact same thing
and kind of mockery
but directed at a different politicians
supporters the outrage in that case
would be nuclear in proportion and
justifiably so
I mean but the left they would go beyond
that I mean they'd be calling for an FBI
investigation probably they they'd be
they'd be asking for hate crime charges
to be filed and I'm not exaggerating you
know I'm not exaggerating but there's
not gonna be anything close to that sort
of reaction here because bigotry against
white working-class people especially in
the south is totally acceptable in our
culture it's one of the last remaining
acceptable bigotries
or with this group of people you could
basically say whatever you want about
them you can make a caricature of them
you can mock them you can cut them down
doesn't matter
and why can you do that well because
they don't count
doesn't count doesn't matter they don't
matter that's the attitude now I don't
spend 20 minutes of the show
hyperventilating over this oh they made
fun of us it hurts it hurts so much
could be my fainting couch I don't want
to do that and on one level I I don't
care what they think of us it doesn't
bother me but there is an enormous
double standard at work here and it's
worth pointing out
it's worth pointing out the the double
standard
because remember
same people especially on CNN
they're doing that one minute
the next minute there
fretting over you know the coarseness of
Donald Trump and how mean and insulting
he is and so on
not to mention they're talking about
bigotry and how we need to get rid of
bigotry if they didn't do that listen if
they would just it wouldn't even really
bother me that much if they were mod
that they were mocking millions of
Americans if they would be open and say
okay yeah this is this is how we are
no we don't care about having respectful
dialogue we don't care about bigotry we
don't care about any of that if we hate
someone we're gonna say it
at least if they took that approach and
they were honest I could have some
respect for the honesty at least
but it's the hypocrisy in the double
standard that annoys me the most more
than the insult it's the it's what it
represents
but really Trump fans should be thanking
CNN for this because this is the most
effective Trump ad anyone could ever
come up with this is millions of dollars
worth of campaign ads right here that
Trump doesn't have to spend so it's 2016
all over again
that Trump may have put a few ads out
but he could have spent no money on ads
at all because the media was advertising
for him and they're doing it again they
haven't stopped doing it for three years
if the people at CNN were to sit around
trying to dream up a way to get Trump
reelected they could not have thought of
a better strategy and they could have
thought of a better 60s or a better more
effective more persuasive 60-second
segment than that
persuade people to vote for Trump if for
no other reason than to do the opposite
of what those people want one other
thing about this because a defense that
you'll hear
with this kind of thing people will
defend it by saying well Trump Trump
mocks people all the time Trump is a big
meanie had himself
which is a very childish defense but
it's also it also misses the point
because yeah Trump can be very mean and
insulting we know that Trump can mock
people and I'm
not even gonna claim that Trump you know
yeah Trump mocks people but he old but
he never punches down he does punch down
arguably when you're oppressing the
United States if you're punching at all
you're always punching now because
everybody is less powerful than you so
he's not above that
but think about the people that he mocks
and insults it's going to be other
politicians people in the media
Hollywood celebrities and that's pretty
much it were other world leaders okay
it's a pretty long list of people that
he's insulted but they're all in that
realm right what what he doesn't do what
I've never heard him do and correct me
if I'm wrong if anyone's ever heard this
I have never heard him mock Democrat
voters across the board that I've never
heard him do
and that's the difference here
this is something that you see on the
left
are increasingly cavalier and blatant
about their their feelings about
millions of working-class people Trump
really doesn't do that
which which should tell you something
kind of a cautionary tale should be a
word of warning for people on the left
that even Donald Trump who has no
compunction about insulting people even
he doesn't do that
all right
so let's go briefly back to the sad sad
story of Stephen King you know we talked
about it a few few weeks ago on the show
Stephen King sent out was around the
time of the Golden Globes I think
and he sent out a tweet saying basically
that we should award works of art based
on their merit based on how good the art
is based on the quality of it and not
based on demographics you know he said
diversity right it's like the point is
not diverse and you want to come start
to come is the merit of the art of the
work of art itself that was the point
that Stephen King made well of course
that is not acceptable on the left and
so the the pitchfork mob came after him
and so he spent the last several weeks
on an increasingly pathetic and hard to
watch apology tour it's just begging for
forgiveness this this this this brief
moment of sanity and clarity from
Stephen King and he he's been begging
for forgiveness for it for the last few
weeks and it just gets more and more
pitiful reading now from The Daily wire
this is the latest in Stephen King's
apology tour
apologizing for his lapse into common
sense daily wire says in an op-ed for
The Washington Post on Monday the
renowned author scolded the recent
Academy Award nominations for their lack
of racial and sexual diversity arguing
that the whole business is rigged in
favor of white folks he says has there
been progress in the film community yes
some I'm old enough to remember when
there were only a handful of
african-american directors and about the
only director of Hollywood was Ida
Lupino who made hard-edged noir be
pictures in the 1950s and later worked
in television but King blames the lack
of diversity among those nominated on
the diversity of the Academy's voting
members noting that they are only 32
percent women and 16 percent minorities
King says not good enough not even
within shouting distance of good enough
King closed out his Post op-ed by
reflecting upon how a perfect world
would be completely colorblind before
lamenting on how that perfect world has
been supplanted by a system rigged in
favor of white folks he writes my
overall attitude that as with justice
judgments of creative excellence should
be blind
but that would be the case in a perfect
world one where the game isn't rigged in
favor of the white folks creative
excellence comes from every walk color
creed gender and sexual orientation and
it's made richer and bolder and more
exciting by diversity bla bla bla bla
bla okay you get the point
just a simpering grovelling yeah you
could tell you he was like on his hands
and knees while probably while he was
typing this weeping along to the
keyboard please forgive me please
he goes from saying listen you know the
issue here is not racial diversity with
art it's just about was it good or not
really common sense he goes from that to
the the arcs are rigged against against
minorities and so on and so forth this
is what happens
and this is why it's you know it's we
talk about having common sense in our
culture how common sense is so important
common sense is important
but I think most people have common
sense that's why we call it common right
if if most people didn't have it it
wouldn't be common sense so most people
have it and there's this illusion we
have I think it is kind of an illusion
that people don't have common sense
anymore that everyone's going crazy I
don't think that's exists there might be
an element of that but that's not really
the problem it's not common sense that
we lack its backbone it's courage
you need to have some backbone and
courage
to stand for common sense and then keep
standing when the irrational hordes come
after you
so Stephen King is not a crazy person
he obviously has common sense
but he doesn't have any curse
any moral fortitude whatsoever
and think about how lacking encourage
you must be to back down this way when
you're Stephen King I mean you're rich
beyond most people's imagination this
guy's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars like fifteen of his books have
been made into movies and he's
completely in a position where you could
say I don't care what you people think
yeah that's my opinion go ahead and go
cry about it some more what are you
gonna do to me what are you gonna do I'm
still gonna have fans even if I don't
I'm rich I'm wealthy I've made my point
he's in a position where he could say
that but so lacking encourage that he
refuses to do it it's hard to watch all
right before we move on a quick word
from Rock Auto you know I have to tell
you I've been we've been having issues
with our with our with both of our cars
actually recently and it's all wait for
it seems like it's kind of a when it
rains a poor situation when you have car
problems where one thing leads to
another another at least that's how it
is for us so I've been getting a lot of
use out of rockauto.com recently
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts tail lamps motor oil new carpet
whatever you want whether it's a classic
car it's the daily driver you drive
around every day whatever it is you need
rockauto.com has it their catalog is
unique and remarkably easy to navigate
you'll have no problem getting around on
the site you can quickly see all the
parts that are available and you could
choose what brand and everything you
want and it's as easy as that
and this is a lot easier than going to
an auto parts store which takes time
first of all and you also have to you
might have to get into the car that's
not working to get to the auto parts
store so that's a problem and then once
you get there most of the time they're
just gonna have to order online the
parts that you need anyway why bother
with that just go online yourself and
get it amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need rockauto.com
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so that
they know that we sent you all right so
Anne Frank is the chief executive of the
chartered Management Institute and she
is arguing that people shouldn't talk
about sports in the workplace
men specifically shouldn't because it
makes women feel left out in an
interview on the BBC she said quote a
lot of women in particular feel left out
they don't follow those sports and they
don't like either being forced to talk
about them or not be included I have
nothing against sports enthusiasts or
cricket fans that's great but the issue
is many people aren't cricket fans I for
one am a huge cricket fan I could talk
for hours about it but I won't and then
but she goes a step further
and she starts talking about
how discussions of sports a discussion
about sports is essentially a gateway
drug
can lead directly into sexual harassment
that's that's her argument I'm not
making that up here I'll play a clip of
that part of the BBC interview listen to
this we were talking earlier you said
one of the points about this is that
football banter can be the gateway to
more offensive behavior to much more
bearish baby is that one of the points
you're trying to make of it absolutely
um it's a gateway to more laddish
behavior and it's a see if it just goes
unchecked it's a signal of a more lavish
culture and it's very easy for it to
escalate from you know the VAR talk and
chat to slapping each other on the back
and talking about their conquests at the
weekend yes a gateway into laddish
behavior a gateway no you gotta watch
out for those for those laddish gateways
because and look she's right I can't
tell you how many times I've been
talking to a guy about sports and next
thing you know he's slapping me on the
back and telling me about his sexual
conquest it happens all the time it's
very normal
actually it's not normal at all and this
just shows something that I had pointed
out before about feminists is that and
this is one of their problems I think
they don't appear to know anything about
men
which maybe isn't surprising that's why
they're feminists but they don't know
anything about men
understand how men operate
and they have this cartoonish idea about
about men it's as if they've never met a
real one before
and all of their ideas about men they
got from watching I don't know
movies in the 1980s or something
so they don't know anything about men
but the bigger issue here with this is
this is another example of well are we
treating men and women equally or not
I mean when when I see a woman am I
supposed to treat her as a woman or am I
supposed to just treat her as a
co-worker irrespective of gender
and talk to her the same way that I
would have man I mean which is it you
kind of have to decide
can't be both it has to be one of the
other
and if it is if it's you know we're
treating everybody exactly the same not
taking their gender into account at all
that's not my see that's not what I
advocate for I think that you do take
gender into account in social
interactions that's part of what
chivalry is all about so I think you
should do that which isn't to say that
you should never talk to a woman about
sports but in general yeah I think in
social interactions you take that into
account that makes sense
well that's not what feminists would say
they would say don't
just treat a woman like a person forget
about her gender completely
well if that's the case then with them
that'sthat's it int then we're going in
that direction you choose that path
completely different path you can't have
it both ways alright let's go to emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from
Maximillian says hey Matt loved the show
I think I found a personality test worth
taking have you ever heard of the big
five aspect scale Jordan Peterson is one
of the people who helped put that
together and I respect his opinion a lot
of things so the very least it's worth
looking into an example of how it points
out the negatives and positives is that
ik i got a 70 cent 77th percentile for
compassion
meaning that i'm more compassionate than
77% of people but it something tells me
I wouldn't be in the 77th percentile but
it gave me a one percent in
assertiveness meaning pretty much
everyone is more assertive than me in my
opinion this personality test is the
closest to reality as I've seen by the
way I agree with your opinion on
personality test most people just want
to hear good things about themselves
I like how you you tell me you got a 1%
in assertiveness and then immediately
you tell me you agree with me so very
very well done illustrating the point
but I mean that sounds like an
interesting take on personality tests I
guess maybe I'll check it out but I
still feel that the whole concept is
arbitrary and sort of weird I mean can
you really quantify a trait like
assertiveness and assign a numerical
value to it 1% why not 3% went on 7% I
mean I think personalities are more
fluid than that harder to quantify
conditional situational based on
circumstance people don't really have
the exact same personality in every
situation so that's part of the problem
now this is from Ian says Matt I agree
with you that personality tests are
useless what is your take on IQ tests
same thing well at least with IQ tests
the person taking the test can't easily
rig it to get whatever favorable result
they want right it's not necessarily
easy to rig an IQ test for yourself so
that it comes back with a 170 IQ you
have to actually do an efficient job of
answering the questions and completing
the tasks and everything but even so I
would say IQ tests are basically useless
also
I you know so pretty much any test
that's supposed to tell you about your
intelligence or your personality I think
it's all basically bunk and I don't know
why we have this obsession with trying
to measure and quantify every aspect of
the human person even the most
complicated and indeterminate parts of
us we want we want to we want something
quantifiable we want a number right now
IQ tests may measure certain aspects of
intelligence but they don't measure
intelligence as a whole it's like if
you're doing a fitness test now a
physical fitness that is something you
can quantify and I think rather easily
measure but if you're doing a fitness
test you couldn't do a fitness test and
the only thing to do when the test is
pull-ups because a person might be able
to do 19 pull-ups and yet be in pretty
bad shape just like a person may only do
five pull-ups and still be in pretty
good shape so there needs to be more to
it than that
the problem with one of the problems
within the IQ test is that it only tells
you about one sort of aspect of
intelligence so if somebody has a high
IQ that means okay they were good at
accomplishing the kinds of tasks that
are on an IQ test
so it means that they're probably good
at detecting patterns it means they can
probably think logically in a certain
way and so okay fine if someone hasn't a
140 IQ you can be pretty certain that
they are for example good at finding and
understanding numerical patterns but
that has that that is not even close to
the full story on intelligence there are
whole other realms of intelligence
personally I think the most revealing
quote test of a person's intelligence is
just to talk to them especially to talk
about an abstract subject or concept I
don't mean talk to them about what they
had for dinner I mean talk to them about
something abstract and as far as I know
about with with with in IQ test it
doesn't have anything to do with that
they don't they don't go anywhere near
that so if you were to say to someone
now I think and even this wouldn't tell
the whole story
but here's my thing he if I could pick
only one test of a person's intelligence
this is what I would choose I would just
ask them a question like I don't know
what is justice some abstract concept
like that and then listen to what they
say it's not about answering it
correctly or incorrectly it's just about
the depth of a person's thought their
verbal dexterity in explaining their
thoughts their ability to grapple with
an abstract concept
now I I think that tells you a lot about
their intelligence doesn't tell you
everything
and I think there are probably people
who would score a 90 on an IQ test which
is relatively low only slightly above
average right and yet if you were to
talk to them about a subject like that
they could give you a brilliant and
fascinating and thoughtful answer just
like there are people who might score a
140 and you try to talk to them about an
abstract subject and they have nothing
to say so that's just one of the issues
with IQ tests all right
this is from dr. Pat says dear met
having emailed you many many days you
never are responses me you're my
favorite person I get many smarter
listening to your mouth I would have
many honors if you read this email on
your show may you having many blessings
in your LIF sincerely dr. Pat thank you
for that emails right very touching and
this is from Heidi finally she says
Matt so based on your raving review of
ad astra I knew that my family and I
should watch it you did say that you
thought it was better than interstellar
my family and I loved that movie so we
were excited to see what this ad astra
movie was all about - crazy psycho space
monkeys later all we we all realized
that was that was two hours we would
never get back the ad astra movie was
more about the human condition and that
you should never cross paths with
monkeys that you've been locked up in a
spaceship for a long period of time
whereas interstellar was more about the
space-time continuum wormholes the
search for life on other planets it was
fascinating it left you really thinking
and pondering about the universe and how
it works
ad astra left us thinking about how much
better it would have been if we never
watched an Astra when you become supreme
dictator will you be subjecting the
people to only watching movies that you
deem as good if this is the case my only
option will be to move my family and I
out of the country it's our only hope
PS my husband and I also watched The
Godfather for the first time ever this
year and we watched about an hour of it
before falling asleep and haven't
finished it since well Heidi you really
buried the lead there because you gave
you this whole diatribe about how I'm
wrong about it had Astra and at the very
end you admit that you have horrible
taste in films I feel like you should
have said that at the beginning you want
you want to lead with that disclaimer I
have terrible taste here's my thoughts
about movies The Godfather of course is
is quite literally the greatest film in
the history of cinema I I can almost
forgive you for falling asleep during it
because you're a woman and in The
Godfather for whatever reason often
doesn't resonate quite as much with
women all right but for a man to [ __ ]
you said your husband fell asleep that's
disgraceful
that's disgraceful as for ad astra look
i yeah you're right that ad astra is
more about the human condition it's more
a more room it of thoughtful film and
that's what I liked about it you say
that interstellar was more about
wormholes in space-time and life on
other planets etc but see that's my
exactly my issue I wish that
interstellar was about those things I
thought that interstellar was going to
be about those things
I remember the marketing campaign for
the movie is what it's one of my most
anticipated movies ever I was looking
forward to that movie
for I mean for months or years before
right when I first heard about
Christopher Nolan making a movie that
deals with these crazy scientific and
cosmological concepts I've been waiting
for a film like that and I'm still
waiting because actually that's not
really what the movie was about they
spend the first third of it on earth
they go into space they visit a couple
of planets go into a black hole and end
up trapped in a bookshelf that's the
whole movie
now the black hole seen the rendering of
the black hole that was beautiful and
very well done almost worth the price of
admission but I was expecting a lot more
spacey stuff than what we got
it turned out that Christopher Nolan
also was mostly interested in using
space as a forum to explore the human
condition which I have no problem with
that and that's what ad astra dozen
other sci-fi films have done the same
thing but I just don't think that
interstellar does a good job of that
their way of exploring the human
condition is to have Anne Hathaway
deliver like 19 speeches about the
cosmic power of love
so both films really were about the same
thing and did the same sort of thing
it's just that ad astra did a better
more subtle job of it and i think was a
smarter movie whereas interstellar hits
you over the head with a two-by-four
shouting the point of the movie into
your ear every five seconds and that's
why I didn't like it but sound like I
say I didn't like it and he was a fine
movie but it wasn't nearly as good as it
could have been all right well I think
we'll leave it there
everybody for watching have a great day
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer austin stevens editor
donovan fowler audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there